we approach and treat fighters in a way
that really makes a fighter first league
fight I have to be putting yeah you have
to put get pro fire behind him and
[ __ ] browner dad for the best descent
amount of them you can't be you can't be
[ __ ] like a baby hey everybody welcome
to another episode of hot box and I'm
Evan Britton and I'm Mike Tyson Mike we
got a couple of great guests today Don
Davis and Ray Sefo of the professional
fighters League yeah thanks for having
us yeah thank for being here guys you
guys have a this is pretty exciting what
you guys have going on so tell everybody
what the PFL is and what you guys are
getting ready to do yeah sure this is
the second season of the professional
fighters League and we're on ESPN
Thursday nights primetime the
professional fighters League is think of
March Madness meets MMA but it's a real
meritocracy no promoter no executive
decide who's gonna win or who's gonna
fight this is all about the fighters
meritocracy and transparency so it's
like any other sports ball explain that
what do you mean so the fighters gonna
say do they do this I want to fight that
guy yes guys make the fight yeah so it
in in football or basketball right now
maybe we'd all wish LeBron was in the
finals but he lost okay so in the PFL 72
fighters start the season we have six
weight classes five men and ones women
there's 12 fighters in each weight class
they get to fight twice in the regular
season the top eight make the playoffs
and it's all things it's more like a
tournament well now think of as a
sociology yeah think of as a season like
other sports regular season playoffs and
championship so if you do the best in
the regular season how many faithful
fees yeah you two fights in the regular
season each fighter fights twice you
qualify for the playoffs so the top
eight each weight class make the
playoffs so once again like March
Madness the eight seed will fight the 1
seed the 7 seed highly long do you wait
in between
fight the fight so normally there's
about 45 days in between fights yeah
so you'll fight the regular season is
May through August you'll fight twice as
a fighter the playoffs are in October
what's interesting about the playoffs by
the month no you'll fight you know once
in May and once in August if you're a
fighter in the regular season okay but
here's what you like and Mike you never
did this as a fighter and you did almost
everything as a fighter the playoffs are
you have to fight twice and win twice in
the same night to make the championship
I've done that in tournaments as the kid
and sometimes you're boxing yes well yet
fight three times a day four times a day
yeah that's right yeah but in in the in
the Commission rules
I mean MMA fights five rounds of five
minutes 25 minutes so obviously if we
had the quarterfinals and the
semi-finals 45 days apart and then the
championship 45 days apart nobody could
remember who's fighting or why you'd
give up on it as a fan so what we did is
if quarterfinals and semifinals are the
same night in each weight class so
you'll fight two rounds of five minutes
the winner will go back get retake
rechecked by the Commission MRI or x-ray
if you need it you have to get very
clear and come back out and then you'll
fight your semi-final fight so you have
to fight twice win twice over me and
I've been fight right Evan wins for Evan
[ __ ] up now I can't fight so what
happens then you know it happened once
last year yeah it did and if Evans not
clear to fight then Mike you would take
to take his spot I mean I was a totally
different situation
I'll Drive totally different for me so
it only happened once last year you know
we had if we had a fighter broke his
hand wasn't cleared couldn't come back
and therefore under the rules you know
the person who he lost came in now it's
interesting that's how you have thought
it you know like a tournament style we
fight three died today four times a day
right right in the championships like a
tournament base you're gonna semis you
go to quarters semifinals right ready
yeah back in the day where there was no
rules - yeah
too long yeah that is just too grueling
look we started the professional
fighters League for fans and for
fighters and it's pretty simple there's
300 mm a million MMA photos a lot of
money out there for everybody yeah
there's all these fans and they only
have one choice you know watch kind of
the UFC or nothing else and if you're a
fighter you've only had kind of one
choice or two choices maybe Bellator or
UFC so if you're a fan this is an
alternative for you to watch if you're a
fighter this is an alternative place we
have more control and more upside
monetarily so you know just like
everything we all don't wear the same
shoes we all know have the same beer we
all don't have the same water this is
just another choice in the marketplace
of MMA absolutely how many fighters you
guys have right you want talk about it
yeah so this year because there's 12
fighters per division okay
and our the weight classes from 145 to
265 which is featherweight and then this
year we've added a woman's lightweight
division and then the women's
lightweight division we only have eight
fighters there so this year I think
that's a total of 68 fighters last year
was a total of 72 plus alternates so
roughly about you get Cristobal we had
earlier she doesn't have a contact with
anybody she that up she's just lost a
great fight but she can come back
anybody can come back yeah yeah you're
right but I think Chris I broke I don't
think I know that she's on the contract
to UFC she still has a contract you add
UFC and matter of fact I she has a fight
I think they shelf dinner um I I don't
know what see why me you know she had a
tough loss in the last fight so I think
fighting is still unpredictable right
you can knock me out right and then you
get a knocked up with him he'd become
the grace and then I come and I beat him
yeah it's not suitable we've seen that
happen a million times a lock-in mmm
even more ways to win or lose right Yeah
right a lot of people look it back to
Chris cyborg she's got one more fight
and then we saw yesterday and ESPN she
said she's gonna talk to all
organizations you know probably
including the PFL
so we look forward to anybody as a free
agent exploring their options
from fighting them what I experienced
them fighting and I'm this is why I'm do
you see it's very successful you know I
mean you have to have the best fight the
best right you know I mean that'd be
evenly matched for people to be you know
anticipated you know yeah you know
sometimes you watch boxing these guys
are so much match but the best fighters
who fight the best fighters because the
promotional grudges between other
companies and stuff and so the greatest
best fighters never get a chance to
fight each other
mmm you know yeah but look there was
something interesting that happened in
pfl 3 last week so we have Johnson it
was Teddy no fighter he's our only
undefeated fighter Mike and he was four
now in the UFC he left the UFC because
he wanted an opportunity to make money
for his family he was very vocal but you
know he wasn't making enough money well
you know what happened his first fight
but his ass kicked in the PFL last week
Wow so a lot of people said hey how good
are the PFL fighters well we just signed
our only undefeated UFC fighter and he
has ass kicked in his first outing yeah
so back to the depth of great fighters
in the world there's 1500 pro MMA
fighters in the world and we've got
fighters from 14 countries so if people
don't think that there aren't great
fighters in the PFL in our mind come
watch what happened why can't I can't
you guys do this I don't know maybe
because it's promotional but listen um
I'm not trying to be a braggart and
stuff but this is what I put it in this
respect this is what my trainer did all
right he took me and he said hey I have
the best fighter in the world
he's probably 15 if you don't believe me
somebody beat him can you do that in
your ultimate fighting MMA I have the
best fight it's almost like putting them
on the chopping block boom he's in the
ring somebody thought they had it could
anybody be though yeah so so are you
suggested we yeah as a brilliant
marketer that you are that the UFC and
Bellator and pfl each put up some
fighters and see yes is that your
brilliant market yes yeah we gave it we
can even make it better if you beat him
I'll give you a million bucks
I I'll do that the PFL will put up the
PSM
right I'll give you a million bucks
that's what my my trainer did this via
training you come to my training we get
the best fighters the best if you knock
him out
I'll give you hundred thousand yeah he's
only 15 if you not come out and even men
well I'll tell you if people didn't say
you were only a fighter will now name
you head of marketing for MMA Global
right for all three organizations but
that's putting your money your money
where your mouth that and we're going to
see are you the best fighter do you work
if I'm the best fighter what I'm saying
half million dollars and he's fighting
the way I fight this is how I fight in
the way I fight nobody in the planet
could beat me I think that me now that
would be nothing so I'll tell you what
just just cuz we're so excited to be on
your show here's what we'll sign up for
then you just gotta get Dana White at
UFC and Scott Coker at Bellator to sign
up for what yeah once we get our
champions from the 2019 season of the
PFL we'll we'll put up our champions and
they could put up their champions and
we'll put up a million dollars for each
weight class let's go hey whoa let's go
Gary go guys and listen by the way hey
and we'll even in Ohio the my car Don
Tyson challenge oh yeah hey listen
that'd be beautiful I like that as well
but listen listen um let's showcase your
friend let's show us what the world have
to worry about us
this is what the world have to worry
about so in this while fans are watching
they can actually go and score points
right or score the fighters score the
fight there's two things very innovative
about the PFL that we've done for fans
first of all we've all gotten used to
seeing data analytics particularly if
you're young you know under 30 you love
to watch it on your mobile phone so the
PFL is the first to ever wire the cage
we call it the smart cage and the data
that comes from it we call ke genomics
so we put chips in the gloves it's with
the fighters consent and we also got the
Commission approval so those chips relay
real-time data that we put on the screen
so so far what we put on the screen is
punch impact how hard did that punch
land so last weekend pfl there was a
thirty point eight mile an hour punch
pretty serious punch not your kind of
punch but you could do way more than
that but pretty serious MMA punch with
those like gloves
we also display obviously strikes and
takedowns
and coming later this year we have
something called the bird which talks
about calories and energy output because
nobody would believe that an MMA fighter
if you do a five-round 25-minute fight
more calories burned in an MBA athlete
in a full 48 minute game so the kind of
things that we'll be showing in terms of
analytics super interesting if you're
not really an MMA fan but you're a stick
and ball sport fan gives you context you
know when the heck's going on in the
fight then obviously later this year as
gambling is approved in more States
those become interesting prop bets that
on your mobile phone you could say hey
I'm gonna bet on what's the hardest
punch in this round and and you could do
that for additional engagement as a fan
we should also in the future maybe when
they put a brain and put a rib put it
hard I put his shoulder and show the
impact for what the impact does when
they hit the great I know heart the
shoulder the ribs great idea you know
well we collect force of impact now look
we collect that data and as Ray knows we
also share it with the individual
fighters if they ask to help them train
it'll become more available to
themselves now it's only individually
available to them themselves and and and
we just use it obviously for the fan
experience and here's your top 10
knockouts of the pho oh he's like a
street fighter man I've had the street
fighter oh yeah he's this D Phi T this
came out of nowhere he's from Hawaii but
he's a beast
oh yeah so ray discovered uh Ray Cooper
and he's back this year he lost in the
finals whose big upset the finals but
he's a favorite this year a particular
fan favorite you know he just got a huge
right hand yeah ray are you in charge of
the fighters and picking them and yes
that liaison between the league yes
that's correct
that's awesome yeah and Mike you love
stories so this Ray Cooper you see on
the screen the Hawaiin yes so his dad
Ray Cooper jr. lost to Jake Shields yes
and that he was fighting yes and Ray
Cooper the son saw that when he was
eight years old cage side and he came
back to avenge his
fathers lost in that fight so he'd be
the old [ __ ] then man yeah young
gave me the old ass [ __ ] man
so so Ray Cooper the third beat Jake
Shields in the retirement talk that just
dad this is the the Sweden Denzel
Washington look-alike yeah Oh
so uh sigh so sighs an assassin Mike and
it's also Todd Gurley who's a big fan of
pfl he was at pfl 1 so you guys have bas
Rutten love boss eyes and uh ready
Randy Couture that's awesome that's
pretty awesome two two legends but they
got experience they know the writers yes
you know exciting ones the ones are
gonna be the fans through the stadiums
and stuff yeah that's beautiful stuff
right there
it's great fighting no it's no
interesting you're showing the
highlights from last year we should note
that we only invited back 36 of the 72
fighters 50% we upgraded 50% of the
roster back to that supply and demand of
Fighters you know there's about 200 free
agents every year around the world
Wow and we had a big demand to get into
pfl this year ray did a selection show
which you ran on ESPN
it was very cool it's an hour show and
you know review tape you know upgrade
the roster and all those divisions
that's awesome
so how do you guys do it no defense in
there Rock'em Sock'em robots so Mike we
gotta tell you so about Sean O'Connell's
guy in the top yeah so awesome awesome
crazy well here's what's even crazier go
over these [ __ ] so he was an underdog
and all four of his fights last year and
he ended up winning the million dollars
really tiring in the middle of the ring
and this year he's our color commentator
on ESPN I would say you need to get in
shape a little though you know get in
better shape yeah but you know he came
out and we did a special on Sean also on
ESPN which you should watch all through
the eyes of Champions
yeah and Sean said Mike when he looked
at his a pony across the ring he owes
he's bigger than me he's smarter than me
he's fast to me he's black belt and
everything and you know what I thought
I've got this guy and he did anyone that
million dollars oh that's beautiful I
mean I wasn't yeah Oh God so ray isn't
uh isn't tiller the guy whose mom comes
to every fight yeah he's his [ __ ]
fighting name is mama's boy yeah yeah
his mom was his biggest supporter she
said she's like round the cage just
jumping up and down yelling we look at
all of the greatest generals in history
that stuff Allah Napoleon Alexander the
Great I'm shoving me to all Mama's
brakes right I just see the to get it a
mother and stuff yes I was very afraid
of my mother said I was a very afraid of
my mother strangers I'm worried those
are long dresses this won't eat my ass
yeah cuz I was bigger than her at about
eight all right look at this one this is
a good oh let's see this Japanese oh man
come on man you guys gotta get in this
this is too easy man you guys gotta get
some more fighter than me I get these
guys to compete with these Oh God you
never took a flying knee did you never
my life when one twin toes look bad yeah
good we had a we had a flying knee and
in two weeks ago that was number one
highlight of SportsCenter first time
Sports Center had a number one highlight
from MMA pfl was a flying knee ten
seconds into a fight and it was brutal
you guys okay that's the first thing you
see when a Waimea is you go wow that's a
great that's a great knockout and I hope
he's okay again come on to see Patek
daddy listen find a Hawaiian guy right
yeah that's right coupe of the third
that's coupe of the wine guy right yep
wrong guy
really strong and focus from Ukraine
yeah
and also young raised only 25 26 which
is very young at MMA this is a child
roaches yeah this is consistent
consistent conscious there's almost like
a little and I'm a Mike Tyson there yeah
I thought you gotta be the rotor
perpetual it's good stuff guys
so Mike as you look at this MMA you
think if you were coming up now as a 12
13 year old do you box or your Mike's
you experiment with money I was getting
you know what was making the most money
but assume that they were even money
similar Stephanie definitely I don't
know it would be difficult different I
don't know don't ever say it's a
different era Yeah right I just wonder
if any part of this ever may appeal to
you as a fighter an athlete listen when
I first thought I couldn't believe it
call you man did you see that [ __ ]
shot I feel then we started watching it
all the time we never stopped when Dan
severance and those guys were there Kim
Shamrock I thought oh yeah yeah you know
and I had these keep watching this stuff
there's no way you're not gonna watch
like that finding so what's shocking
about is broken [ __ ] leg so that's
Alex Nicholson who's back this year
what's you know he's a heavyweight
so to do a fly knee at 265 look I'm a
monster boom it's a big I make one thing
to be a lightweight another thing to
execute that thing at 265 it's just
incredible what the human body can do
and what it can endure
yeah absolutely so I love this this is
Nicholson against them so watch this no
keep watching you'll be surprised to the
Grethe too aggressive watch oh he didn't
have a good defense that's right so he I
always be careful you got for my hearth
is dangerous exactly so see that cut
yeah he had about 20 stitches boom ah
you're right on the door and feet coming
in so Ray and I were both sit there that
fight is about ten seconds from being
called then cuz of there's 20 stitches
over the eye
and he got too aggressive and look at
this doesn't see it comment Wow
to me I don't know about you right that
was the most shocking fight I saw last
year what it just was out of nowhere
right so why is it hit with heavy
weights anything could happen and no way
else because it was so this is
resounding the punch was so rebounded
that you didn't anticipate it with
nowhere to be found in a boom what's the
[ __ ] happened it's almost like magic
look at us there's a great story behind
this this is a championship first fight
of our championship oh so this is the
most money made in combat sports last
year per second so see that that's Lois
Taylor
Oh gave you take that back to your
corner so that's 30 seconds into the
fight Mike and he earned a million
dollars for that Wow now obviously you
can outturn him in your prime but in MMA
that's big buddy so so Louis Taylor is
39 years old and he was an underdog in
that fight and he comes out and what I
loved is and probably can't pull it up
there what he said after the fight so he
brought up his wife and his two kids
Mike and in front of the whole crowd he
goes I don't need no fancy car and honey
the house is paid off here he is and
baby I got enough money for both you to
go to college and that's what I'm doing
with a million dollars and that's what
the PFL is about it's the American trade
mom and entrepreneur building the PFL
this is about providing fighters an
opportunity what they do is up to them
it's not up to Ray it's not up to me if
they win they advance and if they
advance they get a million dollars and
that changes their life and the PFL is
like oh if it is just about opportunity
and that's what we love building this
thing and we love building as a company
and we love help building a sport that's
awesome that's [ __ ] awesome I was a
people ray arm you know I was here LL
Cool J yesterday right and nobody fit
them to me that lost concept sometimes
because I get so competitive I want to
win it and he said some people just
wanna kind of regular right-center Prius
very simple people you know being a
fighter you become you get caught it was
so much grandeur and stuff and you
wanted excitement and all that stuff
some people you saying some people just
ordinary people don't hear nothing quite
wrong something I can't can I have no
concept for that all my life I will talk
about the world is yours you know me I
look at the planet now when I look at
the picture of the planet and I think
I'm on life god I want you that do you
want to chip up for yourself how much
time do you have to do it you know in a
situation like this you can see that in
this situation I want you the world we
want to chill out can this organization
chisel our part of the world forth and I
look at my life in that perspective what
are we going to do is I'm a cannabis
company our Tyson rant there's a little
chip out a part of the world for us and
I always look at it positive perspective
yes it is I see the greatness in it yeah
I know that was really interesting to
hear him talk about that as well because
I'm like that too Mike I'm thinking how
many people's lives am I gonna change
how many people am I gonna impact for
the better what can I do with my time
here exactly I'm always dreaming for you
know stratospheric success and you know
paradigm-shifting impact you know but to
think you know a lot of people they just
want to be able to take care of their
kids send their kids to college you know
put food on the table not stress about
bills and taxes and all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that we have to deal with remind yes you
know I believe our situation like us
being able to comprehend the reality
that we have to deal with our
immortality one day yes you know it must
frightens people cuz I get it a certain
age you get 15 you say well it's almost
over
when you look at it in a perspective
that I was born and now I'm 15 whoa I'm
not the possum I won't be another four
this is almost over what do I do now
and the minutes nothing I can do it
can't stop you oh [ __ ] it's continuing
to go as I figured I breathe effectively
movie what do I do it's gonna come yeah
but that reminds me that reminds me what
we're talking about before the show you
know the tagline of the PFL is what do
you fight for and to be alive is to
fight for something whether you're 54
I'm 57 right although 30
we're all different ages 35 and lucky in
Parkton 31 31 31 but look you're either
fighting for for money for ego for fame
for house for love we're all fighting
for something different and that could
change as you get older
in fact what you're fighting for now is
different for when you were 19
but if you're not fighting for something
you're not alive anymore no it just
changes over exactly I pray now I'm
fighting for to be the best that could
possibly be in life as a human being I
mean even in whatever differences I have
it did have a people that's a rat man
it's almost over
let's see what we could building that's
we're willing to leave behind your word
build is interesting also a lot of
people aren't builders the managers are
there is a just want to take care of
what's there yes yeah right right you
know like to go work it like you know
IBM because it's there right 9:00 to
5:00 yeah you know something wrong with
that yeah you know and and you know and
other people are builders want to do
something new hadn't been there before
you know and to me that's also you know
the fun you know look look what you're
doing this is your third or fourth or
fifth career absolutely right you're
building your building right you know
this is you know my sixth or seventh
career pfl didn't exist two years ago
right everybody said the UFC is the NFL
why even do this you know that's not
unassailable like the NFL we think
there's a better way for fans and
fighters we're trying to do it you know
yeah that's cuz we're builders we're
just crazy enough hate to think there's
a better way and if you're a builder if
you're disrupter you got to sit there
and say you know what I want to do
something a little different I don't
like things the way they are and into me
you know that's that's a different
approach to the world
how's Brock Lesnar's content have that
look at it so you come to the PFL I have
no way that Brock listen this is how it
works all right this I'm probably
talking too much but this is how the
game played the game is known in this we
have competitive organizations you don't
you have to have people on the streets
knowing what's going
it's word of mouth is the easier thing
the word to find out it we all know I
think the best part of the show is all
this work that mics go to for the PF
I'll post the show right that is just
the best part about Miller it's just so
y'all got the young in this you got
really you know this is how stuff is
made you know me everybody's not happy
it's where they're at and we have to get
so what's the word that marketers are
fresh all right thank you
the word day we have some we have to
fulfill our lives that's the word I'm
looking for we have to fulfill our lives
you know people disarmed discarded work
early they need to have their life
fulfilled you need to have their life
together we could fulfill each other's
life and that's how world has worked
that's how it always was that's how it
works with Vanderbilt I work at
Rockefeller that's how I work with
Carnegie that's how you know they we all
work together but still worked apart
they were enemies Rockefeller and
Carnegie theythey despise one another I
believe it with the guy Pat gasps glass
was his name I said eventually he
committed suicide it was some incident
that he believed was caused by mr.
Rockefeller and they always were enemies
that's why I looked on minute did
America hmm that's a good show
oh I love that [ __ ] I inspired me so
much yeah you know that Rockefeller had
to get a loan from he had to get them
here to get the UM the Train he had
usually at the oil has he had to put the
oil and he had he didn't have enough oil
for mr. mandible but he told me he did
and he went to church and prayed and
prayed and prayed and they hit the
[ __ ] guys he had enough but he didn't
have enough product enough oil at first
to put on his trains it's crazy
loved his way through it it's amazing so
hey so you've been around fighting 30
years so what's your advice for us we're
trying to be a fighter first league we
treat them better in several ways you
know they have a guaranteed number
fights little opportunity to make more
money their own control but from your
perspective cuz you got real history
right you bidding around everything yeah
how do we approach and treat fighters in
a way that really makes it a fighter
first league how would you think about
that listen this is what I must tell you
about fighters a fighter has to be um
fighter has to be pushed he had you know
he had to put together put fire behind
him and [ __ ] burn his ass for the
best to come out of him you can't be you
can't be [ __ ] treating like a baby
you can't pamper him that was a good
fire oh I look no [ __ ] we gotta work
you gotta pull your own weight but from
pictureless perspective excuse me and
that's how you get paid you when you get
paid more you want the more money you
[ __ ] get and that's just how it goes
in life if you lose you may not get as
much money but it depends how you lose
if you lose in a sensational fight you
may get the same amount of money or even
more because more people make [ __ ]
Tom you know that's just how it is right
you know you don't take a bunch of guys
and start sucking their dicks and say
huh take some money if you want to lose
no that's not how it go they need to be
on your knees begging give me a fight
I'll fight anybody I'll fight for
nothing that's insane let the world see
me I'll fight for nothing I'll fight
anybody right I'm a fighter person you
know that's what I think that's for my
experience you wanna fight
that's what you want to do let me see it
get him prepare don't get storm in there
and he's not gonna prepare that's what
you want to do let me see you let me see
how beautiful you are
let me see how much you love yourself
how much guts you have matter of fact
show the world I'm putting the camera on
you hmm
so the NBA has always been talked about
as a place that players really love the
league where's the NFL yeah a place
where the players are said they don't
love the league we want to be more like
the NBA mm-hmm you know well can I ask
you when you're that with what you're
saying do your policies on something
like cannabis and CBD and guys being
able to use that as an alternative -
legal you know that should be legal in
the league so I when I think about a
player friendly league because I played
in the NF
and it's very much us-versus-them right
you know and that sucks
and so to me when you talk about a
player friendly league it's really
interesting to hear Mike's perspective
on that yeah you know and I think that
is true for any combat sport athletes
you know it needs to be you know you
need to be have your ass in the fire to
some extent now I think when I think
about a player friendly league I start
to think about like you're saying the
NBA and then you start talking about
drug policies you start talking about
all of that sort of ancillary things
that affect a player or a fighter's
day-to-day experience of being in
business and a sport you know and I
think that so what are your guys takes
on those things you know the boxing and
MMA are still coming by you know the
state commissions you know and those and
those rules ya know just like all right
I would do like this if I'm fighting in
a weed friendly state your guys your
guys gonna have to be tested for weed
but you're gonna be tested for steroids
and all that other [ __ ] you know you're
gonna get the blood test and all that
other [ __ ] all the weight you want if
it's a weed friendly state yeah listen
fighters know they're not gonna get too
high when they're fighting it yeah it
may not get hard today at the fight make
it a hide yesterday they be fortify
tonight for today I'm not gonna be high
yeah that most fighters don't get high
get high today or to fight at a
competition yeah absolutely well I mean
there's a lot of good things happening
you know wada removed CBD so CBD is
allowed the UFC's policy is really
interesting to me we had Jeff Novitzky
in here who's their head of player or
fighter health and well-being or
performance and he oversees all of that
and you know he sees the the insanity of
the cannabis rules you know I mean guys
taking punches to the head you know
you're sustaining this these traumatic
brain injuries our federal government
has done research and shown has a patent
on cannabinoids as neuroprotective sand
antioxidants so they have seen and
proven inside
to the extent that cannabinoids the
chemical compounds found in this plant
actually help protect and heal the brain
from traumatic brain injuries you know
so it's obvious to me that this is
something that fighters and pro football
players football players should be
allowed to consume to aid their recovery
the UFC it just seems like guys can
smoke and then they can't for a certain
a period of time before a fight you know
I don't know what your guys well I think
whether it's the NFL the NBA and I'm a
soccer any sport when you look at all
changes they always start with the
athletes mm-hmm because there is no
sport without the athletes I agree on
right fit so you know what it was free
agency and baseball right how did it
start with the athletes right the league
never says let me tell you what I think
is a good idea free agency right you
know when you rewind the clock of all
major changes it always starts with play
or advocacy than play or leadership mmm
so I believe that what you're talking
about that's the path where it will come
from also whether it's you know from
sport acts or sport why mmm great is no
no you go ahead I was just gonna I was
gonna ask these guys if there's anything
that you know people should know about
or about the PFL happening right now
what do you guys have going on what's
then what's this summer look like yeah
I'll start in a like rate of comment a
pfl season is ten events six regular
season events you know each events about
ten twelve fights and three playoff
events in October and the championship
is always New Year's Eve 7:00 p.m. to 11
live so it gives you something to do you
know deceive on TV right and so we just
finished the first half of the regular
season so all fighters have fought one
time we'll start back in July with the
second half of the regular season Raw
fighters will be able to fight a second
time so once again espn2 live in the
United States hundred 40 countries
around the world on local TV you know
each of those countries but I would
encourage people to follow pfl on
instagram follow pfl on facebook follow
PFL on twitter and say
fighter do I love what stories do I love
what are they fighting for and and what
would you like to see them fight yeah
you know what what what can you really
become part of because this is this is a
place where you can really come to
follow their stories engage in their
journeys which you can't when it's just
a one-off event so we all love a you
know a Mayweather McGregor or a khabib
fight those mega fights are like
watching Mike Tyson is dead we've all
watched those but the PFL allows you to
have that context and narrative of the
stories because it is a season and so I
would encourage people to kind of now
that we're just halfway done with the
regular season tune in and say who is
going to become a real world rocky these
guys fight between you know ten twenty
five thousand dollars a fight six of
them are gonna become a world champion
this year and they're each gonna earn a
million dollars that is a real world
rocky story and if you like that movie
it actually plays out in real world I'd
be pretty awesome I dig the format thank
you and Ray why don't you just give them
like the two or three fights or really
you're really looking forward to because
you actually you've recruited all these
guys from scratch and nobody knows
talent like you not to mention you look
like you could whip some ass I can
probably beat all of them right still ya
know you know we just had last Thursday
we just had the heavyweights and the
light heavyweights go that part of the
decision I was looking for at most 2
because the heavyweights and and the
light heavyweights and I think I kind of
yeah exactly I think i jinxed myself
because I said that we were gonna have
probably about 8 or 10 finishes and we
had 5 so which it wasn't bad let me said
you know that the PFL for July 11th is
the women's 55 division lightweight
division and the mains water weight
division and again you know Ray Cooper
West we saw it up there he's gonna be
fighting on their card there's a few
other guys you know from all over the
world from Russia from Brazil that came
out and and mob lead who actually you
know the worst saw through sports on the
fly need that he
she was able to finish his opponent with
and so you know we've got a lot of good
young talent that that we saw there and
so for me it's because it's the season I
I look forward to every fight and so
just to see who comes through how they
attack the second fight and so on and so
it's exciting to is starts July 11th so
I would just leave you with two thoughts
I think these champions were eager for
the Mike Tyson challenge
so we'll put up a million dollars in
each weight class versus champions
against UFC and Bellator so all you got
to do is get Coker and Dana White just
let me know but in the second thought is
Carla mounted it all right going do have
some balls man go at this [ __ ] man Scott
Coker Dana White on behalf of Mike Tyson
we're glad to put up a million dollars
for each of the PFL champions this year
against your best fighters in those
weight classes for a 2020 pay-per-view
event PFL Bellator UFC Mike yeah do some
[ __ ] [ __ ] instit I mean [ __ ] Scott
yes Scott Coker is in on that is it on
that um the other thing I'd like to
think everybody should watch is Kayla
Harrison Kayla Harrison tell me do you
think the other guys are gonna do it do
you think they think you serious - yeah
they're well they don't look they know
we're serious but they're but they're
not gonna do that
well Mike watches for example yes and
how long did it take for WBC and be
Olivier IBF - even you know you're a
fighter tartars next year I think years
yeah the wide like hundreds and years
everybody their own little island money
and now once your star lose now you
gotta start from scratch again but still
got the money but you could build
another star but once you start losing
so dramatically we can fight again if
they're interested in fights competitive
fighting great fighting keep fighting
and keep fighting right until they get
married right and look weak look we
deeply know they fight so much they
become good friends after half a fight
yeah yeah look UFC has the best fighters
in the world we don't pretend to have
the best fighters in the world what
we're saying is our fighters are damn
good and some of them can beat their
fighters that's what we're saying
really and what look here's the analogy
I would do Julius Erving wasn't playing
in the NBA he didn't have a place to
play basketball in the 60s and neither
did a lot of great basketball players
there weren't enough teams and the ABA
was formed yeah there are not enough
places in the UFC and not enough cards
for great fighters to fight the UFC is a
great organization and they have great
fighters there's just not enough outlets
right now for the great fighters and
that's why the PFL exists dan if you
hearing this stuff Scott you [ __ ] go
he says you're his fighters can [ __ ]
your fighters up don't be scared
now I don't think this kid this is the
this is the first um open invitation
you're giving out no yeah reproach bond
that's the first one and yes yes respect
I'll post Ramon that's a French word
boom ah a real challenge Mike here's a
here's a real challenge that is
everybody would love to see ya Kayla
Harrison is a pfl fighter yes 155-pound
yes
two-time judo gold medal winner yes
Ronda Rousey you've heard of yes one
bronze once okay that's how good Kayla
Harrison is good to be other than Chris
cyborg Amanda Nunes this you should
fight Chris a book with a bug with here
right fables looking for that's the
fight if you want to say what's the
fight it would be interesting to
everyone in the world Chris and Kayla
Chris and Kayla boxes sometimes know
what happened in boxing sometimes
sometimes the guys got two different
guys is let's make the fight and we're
deal with it in court they may hold up
the money and everything let's just have
a fight and we do
yeah yeah but I'm telling you that's a
fight now look chris has got 25 fights
on her in terms of experience
Kayla's quite new the kale is bigger and
stronger hey hey time time then that's
not fit to be the same weight that
that's that's a that's a early 2020
fight that's the same weight through
think I'd be felling they can't be
bigger no Israel no here a long wait
Chris has fought at 145 but she's always
said she's glad to move to 155 she's
always said that okay we gotta get back
in here yeah
but you've just got me riffing on
potential UFC pfl interesting fights for
fans
that's deep respect
hey if the PFL could build a business as
great and as and as successful as the
UFC we'd love that [ __ ] now what am i
kicking [ __ ] ass over reason why
Ray's got me so July 11 July 11th espn2
Thursday night remember if it's Thursday
night that will mean I'll challenge to
get to keep that flowing that's gonna
keep people blood will you put it on
your social - absolutely Kayla Harrison
Cris cyborg [ __ ] 2020 let's go right
July 11th espn2 if it's Thursday
it's pfl MMA night on you come on come
on come on let's work this [ __ ] out and
we're gonna get into Mike Tyson
$1,000,000 weight class chow exactly
that could make them now that we've got
our work done let's go ahead
be tough well thank you good thank you
thanks right appreciated trouble Mike
well you can't escape money can't win
money man
you got time [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] yo [ __ ] and their work on
that talk [ __ ] man no one's gonna get
some [ __ ] on you can't do it man
right [ __ ] way go all out you go all
out
mmm thanks for having thank you guys
[ __ ] from the Jewish debating team on
Instagram Twitter all your social
handles pfl yep yep PFL MMA on instagram
Thursday nights espn2 ESPNU second out
night fight night
great having you guys walk with
everything you guys already buddy Mike
great up hey awesome episode man was fun
[ __ ] challenges without this is
[ __ ] groovy I love this podcast take
us home baby tail also loved you guys be
sure to subscribe on iTunes on Spotify
all those platforms check out our
merchandise on hot box and podcast.com
until next time I'm Emmett and Britain
I'm 8000 Pete please
[Music]